[Music]
water toleration entering into your
fantasy world through an animated map
cliche when the Avatar kept balance
between Water Tribes earth Kingdom Fire
Nation and air nomads oh I've seen this
avatar leaves are not to Holland on her
name is Elsa Olaf dies in this movie
what is it with saviors and stories
always disappearing when they're needed
the most
is this about growing up and losing our
parents damn it show get your deep
psychological musings out of my fun
Nickelodeon martial-arts cartoon scrotum
lips but I have lost hope but you've
lost your eyelashes 15 years later this
title is now confusing people so let me
clear it up this came first the movie
avatar is a James Cameron movie then it
has absolutely nothing to do with this
show and the movie The Last Airbender is
an M night Shyamalan movie that also has
absolutely nothing to do with the show
it's not magic it's waterbending that's
pretty much magic well I'm just saying
that if I had these powers I'd keep my
weirdness to myself I don't believe this
whiny brat at all if he could make the
water bend into shapes and do cool I
need to have a water plume bending
around his before dark no I guess maybe
he would keep that to himself he's still
a brat in a situation like this with ice
coming in from all sides is yelling
watch out help them clearly there are
many things to watch out for maybe a
great job or I'll Bend the water and
help where did that raging current go
exactly just seconds ago these ice
floats were barreling forward and now
that you're out of the boat everything
just slows down leave it to a girl to
screw things up I know right hiring the
first female staff member has totally
derailed my ability to around unnoticed
you are the most did she just call him
nut brain is that like the Nickelodeon
version of calling someone a [ __ ]
okay you've gone from weird to freakish
Katara puberty
let's just get this out of the way now
this show is gorgeously drawn expertly
scored it understands how to be epic
intimate and funny the world-building is
fascinating and the action is clever and
excited plus it's somehow stuffed into a
half-hour nickelodeon cartoon not sure
how they pulled this off but they did so
here's a sin offer each time and an
extra one thrown in for the metalbenders
I mean there ever are metal fenders that
said having your hero's portrait glowing
arrow on his face is literally a bit on
the nose is it not it means my search
it's about to come to an end dude your
kid you act like you've been searching
forever it's not like you're a lost boy
from Neverland or something although if
you were supposed this would be a good
time real bangerang right
bangerang that light came from an
incredibly powerful source it has to be
well good thing the person the most fire
bent on finding him just happened to be
in the vicinity of that brief surge when
a completely unrelated accidental event
revealed him horrible scar angry
eyebrows snarl and we have all the bad
guy cliches well you go penguin selling
with me that is the dumbest pick-up line
I've ever heard Oh unless the penguin is
hey this is a good show how'd you get
the ice and why aren't you frozen I'm
not sure man I guess that is all the
explanation we're gonna get about that
we'll see incased and ice suspended in
air why didn't he need to breathe they
said my flying bison right and this is
Katara my flying sister Socko would be
excellent at sin bending but seriously
for a world where the mystical stuff is
usually so well explored we're just
accepting an airbending Buffalo don't
worry it'll wash out and considering
your entire Parker was stained with the
stuff just five seconds ago
it magically already has you just
sneezed and flew ten feet in the air
that would be to sneeze jokes back to
back and I guess that is an important
staple of anime I'm going home to where
stuff makes sense
bet you wish those super convenient
glaciers stepping-stones we're still
hanging around oh no I am NOT getting on
that fluffy snot monster coincidentally
fluffy snot monster was Mike Ahnold
girlfriend's nickname for my own Kippur
why are you smiling at me like that are
we okay with how heavy this crush is
with these two kids
I mean someone better water Bend Aang a
drink because that boy is we thirsty and
this is the entire village
so incest then what is this a weapon you
can't stab anything with this no not
with that attitude you can't not magic
airbending yeah still pretty much magic
see this makes sense he controls the air
and uses the lift from the kite stick
thingy to fly his little body around but
how does the bison do it your wand does
it made a middle is it that looks very
much like what trust me this kind of
thing doesn't happen when you Tong your
would do it again anger issues the sages
tell us that the avatar is the last
airbender then commercials very well but
first I must finish my roast duck where
was this bowl not on the ground or the
bench so from his robes done we're gonna
live Jesus without courage how can we
call ourselves men
I got a pee good Morgan Freeman is not
narrating the scene can you teach me to
catch one of these penguins but I
thought you said favor with animus and I
guess that means Aang is a liar catching
penguins is an ancient and sacred art
observe this is the second time that
someone has produced food out of the
folds of their clothing and I'm really
not okay with storing food like this and
so it was that Laura and Larry penguin
got ridden a long distance from their
home tribe and were abandoned in dizzy
confusion never to be heard from again
a fire Navy ship and a very bad memory
for my people and a great opportunity
for some more exposition good thing our
ride landed us here wake my uncle tell
him I found the avatar
it really was easy I just had to be
looking through my convenience cope just
as he happened to set off a booby trap
that also happened to be nearby I got
for the script or we might never have
found him yeah cuz it's a TV show
we get how TV shows work my back you
just woke up from a nightmare you forgot
to grab your original cinemasins birch
before it was gone forever cold sweats
leaky eyes loved well I'm here to tell
you that you still have time not much
minutes probably go snag your severely
discounted swag and live your loveless
dreams before your nightmares come true
click below or find the link to our
store at cinemasins calm
[Music]
this Dylan I think I broke a rib
everybody got a water buffalo your new
fat butt well it's no use I'm stuck
teach me the next set I'm more than
ready no you are impatient show me wax
on wax off wax on wax off